was geht hier vor max und heute machen
wir etwas komplett neues und zwar dachte
ich mir so kommt es spielen ein paar
flash games allerdings habe ich mich
irgendwie schwer getan da irgendwas
cooles zu finden das prinzip für flash
games zu zocken bin ich mehr lustig so
weil ihr flash games sind halt irgendwie
fanny so wäre es wenn die mega traffic
sind oder so ansonsten halten mal so
knifflig so minispiel ist halt was auch
immer und da dachte ich mir gibt es
nicht vielleicht eine seite wo man
random irgendwelche minispiele spielen
kann
die gibt es tatsächlich und ich dachte
mir erwacht ich werde einfach spielen
und ich darf dreimal pro videos kippen
das spiel wenn ich das spiel charakter
finde oder sonstwas zu gehen habe ich
sagen klicken sie einfach auf spin the
wheel die ist erste ding da und war
schon geladen
das sei nicht so lustig aus anschauen so
das kriegen wir schon das game
als ob und wie wir machen das mal ganz
schnell vielleicht wird es noch
spannender aber irgendwie ist es nicht
so spannend wie das gefühl
mit dem hengst ab man kann es oder die
sachen ab fehlen hält mal zwei für das
geht nicht
ich habe schon verpackten leute erwartet
aber es sehr beruhigend problemen
anderer runde aber feiner ist das nicht
schön einfach zu dieser wunderschönen
komischen flötenmusik zu entspannen und
dieses tolle spiel zu spielen
hdd okay ich habe alles geschafft
irgendwie ist das spiel relativ leicht
probieren aber das nächste level
aussagen gehen wir danach auch schon mal
den machen schon den ersten skip und wir
uns im nächsten spiel
das gilt das und das hier jetzt kommt
bestimmt wieder leute die sagen hey ich
kann viel schneller diese komischen
steine anklicken
nein wahrscheinlich kommt nicht so
freunde kommen hier das ist aber heiß
kurz sagt okay nicht so spiel okay
matchmaker heißt schöne spiele
wahrscheinlich kann man das alles noch
viel besser machen aber das ja die erste
folge davon
von dieser serie weißen ihr euch den
namen gebe falls ja seht ihr den
bestimmend autoplay klick alle
piesteritz age fjörtoft points schon
wieder so ein geschicklichkeitsspiel
früher das mal aus erhält er vielleicht
fangen immer diese spiele hat er
irgendwann probleme als wirklich sein
spiel nicht irgendwie schwer oder so
sein und irgendwie ist das auch ganz
schnell machen wenn man gut sein will
noch vor einigen das ist vorträge
irgendwie irgendwie haben wir heute
nicht
bisher nicht so dass super glück und wir
wissen die passenden spiele ich bin noch
mal das okay das ist cool cooler
skateboarding perfekt asb space frame
leute die musik das ist der neiße
style.com star david alter wie cool ist
das sind ja und ich komm ja komm
ich weiß genau was ich mache das ist
behindert ich kann wirklich nur um fall
und jetzt frei hättest es einfach so
realistisch ich werde darauf brannten
verdammt noch mal dass ich wenn ich so
plötzlich ich fahre so setzten einfluss
nicht ab und kann irgendwie trotzdem ja
ich mache das aber macht ja mit diesem
los menucos westen nichts ist natürlich
auch nichts für den jungen faust weiter
jetzt erst sagte wright ist es nicht so
dass ich einfach komplett random auf dem
keyboard drauf rum hauer erst behauptet
ist ein dummer hätte hätte ich jetzt
nicht nur ordentlich speed holen
okay leute das ist einfach mit eines der
besten spiele die zeit die zeit die seit
2001 freunde
es war cool gemacht und die zeit läuft
ab
komm gebastelt und werk gottes und
coolen wieder da hingefallen ist
komm schon beim ist nein wirst wie
spinnen noch einmal dass wir eigentlich
davon und reimers kippen
aber das ist ja auch langweilig what you
get
darauf habe ich bock ja da ist die bacon
and gipfel den schinken und afrika aber
es ist ich mache jetzt ist mir
scheißegal ich will da ist
da ist er damit - 100 was für -100 ist
lang hatte wirklich überlegt man
wirklich jedes in kartoffeln eier
brauchen wir für spaghetti carbonara wir
brauchen seine green das heißt sanacorp
bafana bafana steht ja alles was ich
brauche was stand jetzt überhaupt seien
dabei nehmen braucht es aber okay egal
wie kochen passiert
heute mache ich gut oder das finde ich
mache ich sehr gut schneidet das labor
ist aber gar nicht so leicht wie man
denkt irgendwie manchmal gar nicht
angeklickt das wird die leckerste
spaghetti carbonara aller zeiten ok
extra dankeschön an warum legt dieser
kag verdammt noch mal es ist ein scheiß
flashgame ich habe die hälfte verloren
prosit ok stage school rang not ja so
langsam alter da kommt ich will heute
noch essen verdammt nochmal 0 was für 0
das war richtig gut verdammt noch mal
wieso denn 0 da fällt auch die ganze
etwas runter ja als 780 merkte ich hab
langsam den dreh raus
vielleicht sollte man das nicht mit dem
etwa bei spielen auf youtube deaktiviert
nicht das leben hier doppelmoral vor
100 war das gerade am super thursday
bank gehört ok freunde ist geht bergab
es geht bergab water rein da was haben
wir das reizen was ihre reinstetten viel
freude es wird es nicht mehr davon
dank ihnen ein lied das alles aber das
ist echt gut gemacht das spiel muss man
sagen ist ein tolles spiel und es macht
mir eine menge spaß
okay wir haben wir nur
knoblauch drin da ist braucht man nicht
hoffentlich kriegen dann so richtig
ärger wenn nicht als irgendwann aber so
lernt mal so richtig die perfekt zu
lernen richtig die englischen
fachbegriffe diesmal wenn dies glaube
ich aber nicht ab dass derjenige der das
ist dann später dann stirbt so lala für
ein öffnet lasst uns auf heimauftritt
brennen dann wird das surfen dann krieg
wahrscheinlich ärgern hat ich habe
einfach den open schon ausgemacht die
saßen die saßen auch noch nicht final
idee das ready von playboy gespannt
pasta scheiße ernst ich darf das sieht
ja scheiße aus congratulations noch
daniel sache war gut die haben die haben
gesagt das sei gut
ja komm